alrighty folks we are back here doing
more tick tock videos you keep forcing
us to do this because you keep watching
the other tick tock videos and then my
producers are like you know what people
really seem to like you responding to
the tick tock videos let's do more of
those
so if you wish to keep torturing me then
watch this one as well and refer to your
friends this video is sponsored by giant
partners
there's no way out of here
i
wear a mask to school
i wear a mask to school
hi ho the derry-o why we're a mask to
school
it helps to keep me safe
hi ho the derry-o it helps to keep me
safe
nope just notice a couple things about
this video first kid bottom left corner
where's the mask gotcha under his nose
isn't it yeah that's not gonna be super
effective
also virtually all of these masks are
cloth correct there's like one kid here
wearing a surgical mask the surgical
mask doesn't interface properly because
it's an adult surgical mask there's been
widespread data on whether masking small
children in schools is conducive to
actually preventing spread of the
disease the answer is at best
inconclusive you know what helps to keep
kids safe being kids that is literally
the number one factor in keeping kids
safe from covid not the masks not the
vaccines the fact that they are small
children the number of children who are
dying from covet is exorbitantly low
very very very low thank god to pretend
that it is the mask that is keeping them
safe rather than you know their youth is
of course to ignore all possible data
very silly stuff this is all perfectly
logical it's all just follow the science
guys follow the signs this pathway that
i'm on is public space but this park if
you can call that a park is it
it is for the use of the residents only
but as you can see there are no
residents in the park because it's a
park
and yet i can guarantee that this park
fulfills perfectly its role it adds
value to the surrounding properties not
by providing a pleasant space for the
residents but by asserting the
exclusiveness of this complex the only
function of this area is to be a marker
of social segregation
um okay by social segregation do you
mean private property literally every
fence every door every lock represents a
segregation of private property from
other properties that are not private or
other private properties i'm not sure
exactly what he's whining about is the
alternative that there should be no
locks on doors there should be no fences
there should be no gates and that
everybody should have common ownership
of all things because that seems to be
the suggestion here so that's another
reason we need communism this is one of
the many ways in which the space can be
violent in this country oh my god it's
violent space and it reinforces and
affirms social segregat that is not
segregation segregation is where you are
barred from a particular place because
of an immutable characteristic this is
like saying that if i leave my door
locked on my car i have now created a
violent space because of the social
segregation that distinguishes the
owners and users of the car from people
who are outside the car who are barred
from the use of the car the notion of
exclusivity is key to the notion of
personal rights property is an extension
of that i got cornered by three of my
sixth grade students at lunch today and
they came up to me all excited they were
like miss collins miss callings what's
your sexuality
i said why do you need to know that
right now
um and they were like oh i don't know i
just think you'd be like a super fun
like
buyer pan person
and i said well i don't really know how
much i'm allowed to talk about this to
students but
um
does looking at my shoelaces help
what
and these kids just flipped out they
were so excited all right
so either the story didn't happen
which is possible
or the story did happen in which case i
really questioning both the teaching
tactics of this school and the parenting
tactics of the kids
you run up to people and you ask them
about their sexuality and sexual
orientation and then as a teacher you're
subtly signaling to your students your
gender and sexual identity via shoelaces
this is also important it's it's it's so
huge our society what a mature
well-developed society we are what one
enriching society like lives are
becoming so much better because of this
stuff clearly and in case you didn't
know that was sarcasm i still wear a
mask even though
i am twice
vaccinated that's my gang sign why then
also
i don't think you have a gang sign and
if you do have a gang sign that's the
worst gang ever i think a terrible gang
in a gang fight i'm not going to pick
your gang i just don't think it's i
don't think it's going to be a good gang
that's also the sign for wakanda isn't
it isn't it right in that like the
wakanda thing what kind of forever
isn't that cultural appropriation in
some way twice the axe yeah man that's
my gang sign
[Music]
part three of the ways that the world is
just physically built to favor cis men
starting off strong n95 masks often
don't properly fit the faces of women or
agents okay can we stop it right there
sometimes they don't fit people well
because they're different sizes of n95
masks okay
end of story okay next cpr dummies are
almost always male bodied okay stop it
right there cpr dummies are almost
always male body who's more likely to
suffer a heart attack male or female
women often cannot reach the safety bars
on the metro okay i love this one i like
okay this one is pretty great women
can't reach the safety bars let's think
about this one for a second the reason
that women can't reach the bar is
because if you move it significantly
lower people gonna be banging their head
into it all the time
what do you expect like it has to be a
certain height so people aren't ramming
their face into it
we also often can't properly grip
household tools that are made for male
hands okay stop it right there yes you
know who mostly buys household tools
like that drill men people buy products
at different rates based on sex
oh boy okay continue it's considered
totally normal for women to take birth
control and deal with all of these side
effects but barely anybody ever talks
about making birth control for men
wait
virtually nobody ever talks about making
birth control for men presumably she is
unaware that condoms have been a thing
for a very very super duper long time
so yes the bio yes that's that's like
there is birth control for men trojan is
very grateful for that for that
possibility
i'm sorry that reality doesn't cut in
favor of the silliness
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll get some more woke tick tocks in
just one second first every single
company strives to have unique values
and a long lasting impact
when we started daily wire one of the
things that we knew we needed was a data
driven approach we needed heavy focus on
marketing this is what giant partners is
there to do it's time to position your
company as an industry leader create
buzz attract new customers and generate
consistent revenue and giant partners is
here to help you do it they're america's
number one data driven marketing agency
giant partners operates in the business
to business space offering a variety of
business marketing solutions like
database marketing brand development web
design seo lead generation digital
marketing services as well as ad
placement that's just to name a few
whether you own a small family business
or handle millions in revenue each year
giant partners can help you get to the
next level their marketing strategies
are research driven they are equipped
with 20 years of data experience don't
take my word for it their largest
customers include bmw nationwide ohio
state university 3m and ethan allen so
head on over to giantpartners.com and
get your business set up today they can
help your business grow in unique
amazing ways head on over to
giantpartners.com to get started let's
talk about chairs uh
intended chairs are the biggest
issue
in the fat community um the amount of
public spaces like doctor's offices
malls what the ever places that
have seating
restaurants etc
never ever have accessible seating if
you have never
looked at a picture
of a restaurant on google maps to try
and figure out if the seating would be
accessible to your size
if you've never broken a chair in a
public space especially
um if you've never had to second-guess
whether or not it was okay to sit down
in the chairs provided to you if you've
never had a panic attack at
school because you couldn't fit into the
damn chair desk situation
then you don't deal with fat phobia at
the same level that the rest of us do if
you sat down on a chair in the chair
breaks which
if that happens
is the chair fatphobic listen there are
people who have genetic predispositions
toward obesity and that's really sad and
that's really terrible and that's that's
really you know unfortunate but the
notion that all chairs everywhere are
supposed to be built with the
possibility in mind that you are 200
pounds overweight is insane this notion
that all of reality has to conform to
you that no one will ever have to
experience any level of discomfort
because they differ from the average in
any way which seems to be a common theme
of these videos is really self-centered
and really
stupid is right up there with capitalism
and killing people and making this world
a miserable miserable place so you
practicing catholicism means that you
are no longer my mother no longer
someone i look up to and you're just as
bad as the person who murdered the cow
to make that hurt
so go ahead carry your dead cow around
walk in your catholic church and listen
to them preaching bigotry and hatred and
you can just become a freaking
republican if that's what you really
want to be because you won't go to
another freaking church
that's pathetic
i feel that parenting has gone wrong in
many ways man
the the people who believe that they are
just the most morally virtuous among us
tend to also be the most obnoxious among
us
if you espouse to the idea that jesus
was born of a virgin birth
then jesus could not have had male
chromosomes therefore jesus
had only female chromosomes and
presented as masculine so
jesus was non-binary and in terms of
male and female and the hebrew the word
that was used for and
describes a spectrum
male and female and everything in
between
i am not an expert on christian theology
but my understanding is that the idea is
that jesus was both fully human and also
fully god is this correct christians
anywhere around here yup yes this is
correct okay if that is indeed the case
then jesus would have had to have the
full chromosomal slate in order to be
fully human this means that if jesus was
male he was male that's a man now
let's talk about the the bizarre
invocation of hebrew here there is no
word for and in hebrew there's a prefix
in hebrew for and it's the letter of and
in hebrew means the same thing that and
in english
does it means this thing and that thing
it does not mean a full spectrum that is
incredibly silly
that is bad hebrew grammar i'm out of
here i've got hebrew school
so the people who watch tik tok are very
young people
this is sort of bleeding edge crazy but
here's what we've learned over the past
couple of decades bleeding edge crazy
eventually becomes mainstream crazy so
if you want to see what's coming down
the pike in terms of our society all you
have to do is watch a little bit of tick
tock and it makes you want to
immediately take the first spacecraft
out of this place i don't want to live
on this planet anymore thanks for
suffering through this with me if you
enjoyed the video please like subscribe
leave us a comment below maybe recommend
some other tic toc videos you'd like to
see me respond to we'll see you here
next time
i can't do this anymore